he's carson palmer's former Bengals
quarterback iseman Trophy winner at USC
and he'll tell you what he is joining us
on behalf of coming up here in a moment
how are you Carson I'm well Dan thanks
for having me yeah I was curious when
you were leading into the draft leading
up to the draft in what 2004 were there
any rumors about the Bengals or o3 the
Bengals trading that pick you know feels
like there's all these rumors leading up
to the draft every year I'm curious did
were there any rumors circulating about
you and the Bengals no I mean probably
two or three months before the draft I
really started to see you know clear
that they were going to take me you know
you go through the interview process
you're talking to coaches on the phone
you go out and visit visits organization
and visit the facilities and meet with
the coaches and meet the players and I
could tell pretty early on that they
were they were going to draft me and
there really wasn't a lot of talk I know
Chicago was right behind the Bengals
that year I think I like three or four
there was some talk that maybe they
would they would move up but really it
was it was pretty clear-cut and I knew
with a couple months up coming up to the
draft that I was gonna go to sensi any
apprehension going to Cincinnati not on
my end I was really excited I remember
going through we got them we played in
the Orange Bowl and January and then I
started bouncing around the different
agents and meeting with different
agencies trying to figure out which
agent I was gonna pick and a number of
agents had you know plans to to get to
this team or get to that team and I
ended up choosing Dave done an athlete's
first and went with him and had a great
career together and and he just kind of
said what do you want to do and I said I
wanted to be the number one pick I just
went out and trained and got ready and
got ready for the interview process got
ready worked out so all the things that
came up but there wasn't a whole lot of
talk outside of my camp about anything
other than getting ready to play for the
Bengals
you start to look at these prospects
draft picks in with Joe burrow now we're
starting to hear well he doesn't have a
strong arm and and that's true he may
not have a strong arm I always get
nervous when I hear when somebody leads
with bullies got a big arm like I don't
I don't care if my quarterback has a big
arm I want to know if he has a good arm
an accurate arm but you know if I look
at what Justin Herbert has and I what
look at what Joe Burrell has I can see
why Joe burrow is considered a better
prospect because he does have better
accuracy he can throw you open where
Justin Herbert has athleticism here what
should we really be looking for
listening for when it comes to these
quarterbacks and how it's going to
translate into success in the NFL yeah a
big arm is great and it's sexy and it's
fun and in and Asya but if you can't
find the soft spot in the pocket and
create space within the pocket while
your eyes are downfield reading a
defense finding the open receiver and
then deliver the ball accurately under
pressure just as you're about to get hit
right in the throat nothing else matters
big arm tight spiral all those things
are all irrelevant you got to be able to
deliver the ball on time while you're
getting hit and also have some savviness
about you moving within the pocket so I
I'm I'm on I do the same thing I hear he
threw the ball 75 yards you know off of
one leg or you know some silly stat
that's totally irrelevant you got to be
able to deliver the ball under pressure
all game long for 16 games and that's
you know one of the knocks maybe onto it
is is the injury history and you look at
all these injuries and all these little
things keep creeping up you know at the
end of the day if you're not able to
play weekend week out and deliver the
ball accurately it doesn't matter how
strong - yeah I start to look at - and I
know everybody loves the way throws the
football and they say he's a left-handed
Drew Brees which is way too much praise
for you know twoa
because he he doesn't strike me and he's
six four nobody's saying he reminds me
of Drew Brees it's he's six foot so
therefore he's drew
I think I see more of you know maybe
Russell Wilson with that athleticism he
does get out of the pocket a little bit
but he does have great touch and appears
to be able to have all the throws that
you want aside from the injury issue and
granted that's a big issue what concern
or concerns would you have about to at
the next level outside the injury issue
I really love everything you know that
injury issue is a it's so easy to sweep
that thing under the rug well he's got a
big injury issue but X Y & Z know it all
starts with there if you're having a
difficult time staying healthy in
college it really worries me that you're
gonna be able to stay healthy for you
know 30% more games 40% more games and
bigger you know more physical guys
hitting you and potentially injuring you
so I mean that injury thing really is a
is a big deal but the other thing that
kind of jumps out at you is when you
watch his film he's playing with NFL
receivers and not just in a photo
receiver you playing with first and
second-round picks you look at these
receivers they have on that roster man
it'd be hard not to be productive at
Alabama and in that offense when you've
got Henry rugs and you have some of the
speedsters that they have on the outside
they have two or three guys in Richards
second round picks Judy does well Jerry
Judy can absolutely I mean Jerry Judy's
probably a top twenty pick and you could
probably say the same thing about Henry
rug so that that does concern me a bit
would you take him if you're Miami if
you're your they're in fun you would not
know the injury thing worries me okay I
love his game I love his leadership I
there's so many things that that you
fall in love with him but at the end of
the day one of the best abilities in the
league is durability and if you're not
durable in college it's just you really
you very rarely see guys that are that
are durable guys I call it and they get
sianeth also they're healthy every week
that that thing jumps out at me and
worries me about twoa he's carson palmer
the former number one overall pick
joining us on behalf of levels select
CBD dot-com explained that you've been
involved with
this for for quite some time have you
been involved with CBD as long as Jake
plumbers been probably not as long as
Jake has but it's I've been using it for
I've been done playing for three years
I've been using it for four or five it's
something I use every day now it's funny
we get done talking about injuries and
go right paid really but ya know it's
something that's a part of my life it's
something that I use it as you remember
I've had multiple knee surgeries I've
had plenty of surgeries but I have some
some serious ailments and some serious
issues with just consistent pain and
consistent aches and level select is
something I use them I need something I
use them I go back I've got four young
kids that I'm consistently playing you
know my son wants to be a pitcher so I'm
down and in a catcher stance and you
know my daughter wants to ice skate and
I have to go ice skating with her an ice
skating is not great on knees and low
back so level select CBD is something I
use just to get me through being a dad
and and and feeling good waking up in
the morning and feeling good and
sleeping well at night it's something
that is a part of my life
would you rather your son played
football or baseball for me football
because I have a really difficult time
sitting and watching baseball game but
for him for him football - he loves it I
mean it's it's something that that we
put off we have not let him play yet
he's going into sixth grade next year
and gonna be 12 and I just you know it
worries me I just don't think he needs
to be getting hit in the head already
and have you know all these little
things start creeping up you know I'm in
junior pot we need junior Pop Warner
football we been pushing to let him play
once it gets to high school but he
finally broke broca's town and he asked
every single day for I think like four
months straight and then you combine
that in the quarantine and you're
getting asked in the quarantine if I can
play football if I can play football if
I can play football and so finally we
broke down three nights ago and told of
my we're gonna let you play tackle
football next year so he
he's super into it I'm super into it
obviously and yeah trying to start we've
been training since the quarantine
started and getting ready for the season
hopefully that it gets here to fall what
advice did you give Jill burrow uh when
we talked we really had just talked
about the process and I said one of the
most important things is just you know
when a team gives you an offense and
gives you protections just digest it and
be ready to spit it back so really it
was we've we've talked very briefly
about preparing for the process the
combine the draft the pre-draft workouts
the pre Jeff meetings and really just
you know kind of gave him some insight
on you know what it's like to go through
you know and and just kind of small
tidbits on getting ready for the draft
would you rather have an all-pro wide
receiver an all-pro lineman all-pro
alignment okay because you start to see
where we focus in on the skilled
positions we always do that then every
year you'll go oh you know you drafted a
tackle drafted a guard or Eve is a
garden college and we're gonna make him
a center here and we we never talked
about that because there's nothing sexy
about that but the importance of that
the offensive lineman and trying to find
these linemen because the way college
football is played is it's different for
the linemen and you know how far the
spacing they're the blocking the strata
you know all of those things and it just
feels like we get to the draft we're
like I hurry up let's get to another
quarterback or wide receiver running
back we don't care about linemen though
did you ever get involved in the draft
with the Bengals or any of the teams you
played on you know to say hey I could
certainly use another lineman that was
always the first the first words out of
my mouth we could always use another
tackle another guard on another center
but they're not sexy they're not they're
not fun from a fan's perspective that
you took a guard from Villanova and the
third round I mean that's just not that
doesn't you know being a you know a
Cardinals fan of Chiefs fan a Raiders
fan whatever it is that doesn't jump off
the screen but at the end of the day
if you can't step into throws and you
can't get to the top of your drop and
get from your first read and your second
read to your third read as a quarterback
man it doesn't matter if you took three
first-round receivers three years in a
row if you don't have the ability to get
through the timing and rhythm of a play
to get the ball to these exciting sexy
receivers that you drafted and fan bases
go nuts for the mat guy that you draft
in the first round that receiver is
irrelevant
I think every quarterback it's fun to
get a new toy outside but man it is a
necessity to have guys that can hold up
in front of you and they're so hard to
find and they are so hard to coach and
it just seems like these athletes get
moved if you once you get over 250
pounds these great athletes get moved to
defensive end and these offensive
linemen are having a block I mean you
look at today v & Clark Jadeveon Clowney
6 7 and he ran like 4 4 at 275 miles
Garrett I mean some of these guys
they're getting so big and so physical
and you look at chase young it's just
hard to find a guy that can block him
for four seconds and it's a necessity
every year there's more and more of
these freak athletes coming out that
they put their hand the ground and get
after the quarterback and you've got to
have people two blocks to them if you
don't if you don't have people two
blocks on them it doesn't matter how
many first-round picks you use on
receivers and tight ends and these these
fun like like we're saying sexy toys
outside to throw to you know if you
can't get the ball to them they become
irrelevant if chase young is considered
the no brainer best player in the draft
why isn't he going number one that's a
great question I think that's you know
at the end of the day when you're
looking at Andy Dalton who's currently
under under contract for the Bengals who
is a really good player I mean he gets a
knock mainly because he played for the
bangles but Andy Andy can play and and
Andy can he may not be a number one pick
and may not be that that guy off a draft
board but Andy's Minich
tremely extremely productive and and you
got a chance to get you know a guy that
that can probably get after the
quarterback 14 to 15 to 16 times like a
von miller type career a defensive end
that guys hard to pass up and the other
thing about chase young too is he's
great in the run game so because we
don't know about Joe I mean Joe burrow
is not a given as much as we want to say
boy he's unbelievable okay he had the
the greatest single season in college
football history at that position like
you know I grant you that
it's not a given if chase young is a
given then that I don't know maybe I'm
over 18 chase young but it feels like
nobody wants to trade up to get chase
young but everybody keeps saying boys a
generational player alright I know you
want to find your quarterback but if I
got a guy who can line up there and he
can give me 10 years of all-pro status
and you would probably sign it if I said
he can give you 10 years as an all-pro
or you roll the dice on Joe burrow who
do you take man I mean that's that just
shows you how important and in the way
that the league thinks about the
quarterback position is just how
important that position is no doubt I
mean you think back to the mario
williams Reggie Bush Bush draft and Mike
OH six or seven whatever that was where
Mario Williams went number one everybody
could not believe that Reggie went
number two I know Reggie's not a
quarterback but when when people were
looking at that they they couldn't
believe that that happened but Mario
Williams went out got 12 to 14 sacks
just about every single year's career
that's what chase chase young is
projecting that is what you expect at a
chase there you're exactly right there
is a ton of unknowns on Joe he played
one year college football it is
extremely risky right but you got to
have a quarterback and and that position
is as we know it's it's the position you
have to have every team that's that is a
Super Bowl contender has a quarterback
so until you have that guy you're always
you're always looking for
now Andy Dalton still is under contract
chase young you know as you're saying
could be the best player in the draft
probably is the best player in the draft
I think it's a really difficult decision
that they have to make they have to
either pass up on a guy that's a 14 sack
guy or go after a guy that could be the
future of your franchise and handle the
quarterback position for the future of
your franchise for the next 10 to 15
years it's obviously a big decision a
difficult decision good to talk to you
it's level select CBD dot-com creams
roll-ons and helps you live life after
playing NFL quarterback for as long as
you did I hope you're doing well and the
kids are being nice to you well good
thanks Dan good to catch you up man
that's Carson Palmer level select CBD
calm